I think you'll see that the labor party
uh delivered the Good Friday agreement
that actually ended armed civil conflict
in Northern Ireland and don't forget K
that we delivered the Good Friday
agreement in 11 months this government
has spent two years rallying and talking
and trying to negotiate to try and just
restore some of the trade barriers put
forward within the United Kingdom by the
previous deal now we have progress but
just just remember what that progress is
you can now buy the same sausages in
Belfast that you can in Birmingham or up
in up in Scotland that's what's been
restored by this deal because the
previous deal put barriers in so you
couldn't actually buy sausages in in
Northern Ireland so it's good that we've
made progress now all eyes turn to the
politics of the situation I hope the dup
have all the space in the world they
need at the moment so that they can
assess this deal see it working in
action ask any questions address any
concerns that they might have because
the real real imperative now is getting
devolved government up and running in
Northern Ireland you know better than
most if the dup does not accept this
deal is it dead in the water
I think it would be very very difficult
for this deal to become a success now
the deal can get through Parliament
because labor party will support uh
provide the votes to do so disability so
we will be supporting this this deal
okay but this is that's the deal getting
through onto statute the next challenge
is whether deal can be made to work and
it'll be very difficult for the deal to
work if you don't have a developed
government up and running in Northern
Ireland so the the assembly and the
executive both of which need the dup to
go in and act within it so I think the
government as the government here Richie
sunac has got a big political challenge
ahead because don't forget that the
Devolution collapsed the dep withdrew
because of neglect from Westminster
because they were ignored when their
concerns were raised from within the
administration once they pulled out they
were rewarded with being engaged with
and they had power in this process now
what they are going to be judging is
will we have more influence if we go
back into Stormont or where we have more
influence if we remain outside that's
the trick that Rishi sunak now has is to
reward functional Behavior within
Stormont so does the dup still have the
whip hand it does yeah of course it does
because the foreign secretary wouldn't
say that they did no but they do but
let's just be clear again we will make
sure that this deal can become law in
this in the UK we will we will make sure
the labor party that it can become a
deal that's signed by the maybe however
in Northern Ireland which is then not
helping precisely yeah but the next
challenge is to be making the deal a
success and in order for this deal to
become a success then devolved
government needs to be restored in
Northern Ireland that needs the dup to
go back in what percentage success are
you giving that uh I I wouldn't do so at
the moment because I think part of the
problem is that well with regard to
Northern Ireland we're always jumping
one step ahead what we need to do is
focus on the moment we have at the
moment before us we have an incredible
window of opportunity to get things up
and running we've got a deal which takes
us forward we have the opportunity to
get Devolution up and running again so
let's focus on what we have before us
quite often things fail because people
ask questions about possible outcomes we
focus on the possible outcomes which
makes the negative more likely to happen
yeah but we've got a U.S president who
wants to come over to celebrate the
anniversary of the Good Friday agreement
he's not going to come if this Deal's
not gone through now look okay I agree
with you which is why we were saying
this needs to be nailed down a long time
ago it took 11 months to negotiate the
Good Friday agreement it's taken two
years to negotiate out some of the
problems baked in by the previous deal
which is sunak voted for so it should
never have taken this long that's what
the labor party was saying all the way
through that's why Kia was saying a long
time ago get the compromise get the
negotiations get talking rather than and
end the rowing and we can get this over
the line which is Soon As proved that's
possible the question is why did he try
and do this a long time ago a subject
that is very close to my heart and to
lots of our viewers this morning a new
action plan supporting the well-being of
Staff going through the menopause I was
reading that um 10 of women leave their
jobs because they don't have the support
they need during the menopause 10 900
000 women a year what all about uh well
yes but also this is a pressing issue
because now the the largest number of
people in the workforce are going to be
women in their 50s and it's the biggest
growing part of our Workforce more
experienced I like to call us yes yeah I
I agree and I think I think actually
that's right
we'll do demonstrate in that because I
was texting friends early saying I'm
about to be Burly so um but yes but it
needs to be taken seriously and now
annalize Dodds from the labor party has
announced our policy on it which would
require any business who has more than
250 employees to have a menopause action
plan good so it just means that they
need to tailor plans within their own
specific workplaces so there's not one
size fits all but each workplace because
some of them for example will require
uniforms perhaps those uniforms need to
be adapted in certain circumstances
other places will work in a temperature
regulated environment perhaps they need
to think of that as well so all these
different things couldn't be applied in
different ways but every business over
the size of 250 employees will be
required to actually have that plan in
place that's right it's always so I see
yeah and it's not just the questions
it's good to see I'm glad to know that
I'm a verb it's good to see you thank
you very much Cindy for joining us thank
you